life is short is so pleased to have bud
light seltzer as our presenting sponsor
listeners know that we're big fans a bud
light seltzer it's a delicious hard
seltzer from bud light but it has no bud
light in it that's right each one is
just 100 calories 5 alcohol by volume
and gluten free the retro summer pack
has been our go-to drink it really has
we've been lucky enough to like spend
some time with family at the lake and
doing all those summer things never far
away is our retro summer pack i mean i
love that summer ice it's so hard to
beat that i know you like the blue
raspberry a relative of ours they went
crazy for the cherry limeade and thought
and thought you're cr how are you not
enjoying this one the most so we love
partnering with bud light seltzer to
bring you some of our favorite summer
memories and we've got more in store
later in the show so stay tuned
[Music]
the name lorne michaels gets mentioned a
lot on the show we have a lot of center
and live cast members as guests and he's
like the grand poobah of comedy do
people say that anymore grand poobah i
don't think it's ever been a set on this
show no i've never said it puba are
there other pupas or do you have to be
grand to be a pupa
uh you don't have to be grant to be a
poopa you could be a minor
a lesser poopa
um but laura michaels is not a lesser
poo but he is the puber the grand poo of
comedy and um my dear friend drew
barrymore once she did a very kind thing
among many kind things that that she has
done in my life she basically allowed
facilitated
like an impromptu audition for lauren
michaels we were at a dinner and um it
was a loud restaurant it wasn't the best
atmosphere for comedy she just talked up
how good she thought i was at
impressions and and he said oh who do
you do you know like
slightly interested maybe and i said she
said oh he does matthew mcconaughey does
michael j fox you know so i started
doing a few for him and um i don't think
he even gave like a consolation laugh
you know it's just kind of like okay
um
well at least she didn't have you do
your canadian impression
that was that would have been a treasure
i was about to just launch into it that
would have been bad and he is canadian
right so he would i think so so i think
he would have been insulted in two ways
like both as a comedy puba that it
wasn't funny and as a canadian that it
wasn't accurate speaking of pubas here
we go that these two pupas are about to
start the show
life could be a dream life could be a
dream
[Music]
you're listening to life for sure i am
your um lesser puba host justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always is um
i would say a grander puba i bet at some
point
someone has referred to you behind your
back as a puba
oh really like as it just has an insult
not necessarily what is a puberty it
could be someone who really likes you
too
but i can guarantee you no one's ever
called me a poop until you think until
now
you calling me a poopo is the first time
anything's ever been said on this planet
yes why do you think people have called
me a person holding many public or
private offices a person in high
position or of great influence
the clue on jeopardy i think it was
something to like uh
it wasn't a.a milne who coined this
uh term it was gilbert
sullivan yeah i'm a clue i didn't know
that i'm reading it oh yeah but that was
the clue in jeopardy no kidding it's
from the mercado mm-hmm i didn't know
the mikado was from 1885 gilbert and
sullivan i didn't know they were
that old
they're dead i know i know they are but
uh i don't know um oh they're they must
be really old right now
hey
wow how come no one ever told me that
gilbert and sullivan are the oldest
people alive on the planet wow they're
they have cool facial hair look at that
they they have like arthur chester art
oh really cool yeah especially who's
that sullivan on the left sullivan is on
the on the right sullivan is the uh
younger i prefer gilbert's facial hair
but they're both that was a big look who
would you prefer gilbert's solo
yeah gilbert's cooler because he's got
the twirly mustache but it's hard to say
maybe sullivan grew
into that look a little bit later uh
you know they one was younger yeah okay
so
ws gilbert was younger we've gotten way
off course i know i know uh i i'm but
now i'm curious about them were they
now how do i say this without were they
gentleman lovers yeah
um why is that delicate to say i should
have just come out and said it i'm too
nervous i think we would know if they
were no not but not at all
i don't mean like privately they may
have been but i'm saying publicly
we would know if they were if they were
a couple publicly you think oh yeah or
if they were a public couple yeah yeah
we would have known about that why are
we talking about lauren michaels though
yes let's get it back let's get back
okay let's get it on track lauren
michaels we're talking about because
he's got a very distinct you know not
only his voice but it's a distinct
energy too and it's the energy of a
person who has power who doesn't need to
go out of their way to connect you know
the people come to him and so it's this
very kind of um
you know what do you have for me sort of
uh energy and one of the most famous
impressions of lorne michaels was done
by well two bit dana carvey and mike
myers both did
an impression of him that was that was
really funny but michael mike myers did
one uh in a movie called austin powers
so
his character dr evil is directly based
on lorne michaels
and uh
and and not that laura michaels is evil
but they have very similar voices yes oh
yes it's this i'm not doing a very good
one but it's pretty good one edge short
yes a bit of this and but again dr eva
also has that oh that kind of plotting
energy um mike myers hopefully future
guest of the show i know that'd be great
but current gas yes also great also
great is played dr evil's son
in that franchise scott evil scott evil
she's such a good name for that
character so good
it's one of the funniest parts of that
movie i think and
our guest today is the very funny such a
good actor always has been
uh seth green
and i say always has been because not a
lot of people when they're they're
starting out that young because seth has
been an actress since he was a kid um
and he was always he's one of those rare
like really gifted child actors who
transitioned into
uh being a gifted adult act it's it's
rare everyone knows seth green even if
you haven't seen the austin powers films
you may have seen
can't harley white why oh cat hardly
white
that's the remake that's the cancelled
remake freudian slip because that entire
cast is white i'm pretty sure um there
are a couple d um
they're sean
patrick thomas i think yeah it's hard to
say but it's a very white cast because
there's a sean patrick flannery right
that's but it is it in my defense it's
very very white and hardly white that's
that's funny that's funny it is but he's
great in that and uh buffy the vampire
slayer he was on that oh yeah that's
he's right
in everything uh uh
movie radio um radio days by a director
we can't mention um
was
i think his first big thing um so he was
a kid kid then i think he was like nine
or ten
anyway we get into that we get into a
lot um about his how he got started and
how he became so well adjusted because
robot chicken creative robot creature
yep of course and um so many things seth
has been like christian said around for
so long i i'm sure you all know who he
is but um now you're gonna learn a
little bit more about him and uh what
what makes seth green
seth green i can't wait i can't what i
can't wait i can't
i can't hardly walter white
um so here it is if you can't hardly
wait
uh here it is you don't have to wait any
longer for
my ketchup i haven't seen him in a long
time uh my old
my old actor acquaintance
and now friend seth green
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
so are we we just two cranky guys cranky
old guys yeah
yeah i've been wearing my hair cardigan
sweaters since i was 16. like i've been
doing these kids in their music since
since i was
13. that's funny you've always struck me
as having an
older yeah you've always seemed mature
to me i know that you were around since
you were acting at such a young young
age you were around a lot of older
actors and the things that you took from
them what how much of that experience do
you think shaped you
i think it's everything i mean i started
professional being professionally
employed at seven years old and even
though i was a little kid still
discovering myself and making all these
you know intellectual connections or
decisions about the way the world worked
i was getting the benefit of of people
influence from people who
had been doing it their entire life so
when i was seven years old i was working
with actors that had been working since
they were children like i hear a lot of
kid actors talk about
the terrible or horrible experiences
they had and i i really just think i was
incredibly lucky neither of my parents
were
particularly
intent on me
succeeding
it wasn't their goal it just wasn't
their goal like they helped facilitate
they really encouraged me but it wasn't
anything that they wanted was that was
it just something you enjoy doing and
you grew to love it yeah it's it's it's
funny and when i
because it's my story it's never seemed
out of the ordinary but the more i
relate it to other people who've grown
up in similar situations the more i
realized that it was kind of unique um i
was like six years old and i had grown
up loving
um
mimicking things doing voices i loved
putting on shows i loved
using my imagination to draw to tell
stories to paint to sculpt to
perform to i don't know were you
surrounded by that seth were your
parents were they very creative people
did was that part of your household sort
of not really my mom's a classically
trained artist and she was a teacher for
several years and my dad say
math and computer sciences teacher and
he was a
department head of math and computer
sciences at a creative performing arts
school for like 30 years and
with i think with both of those points
of influence i had a lot i had a lot
growing up available to me i had all of
my mom's um records or
art books or um we would go to the
museum and i was just exposed to a lot
of different kinds of people
my mom
was the
art director at two different summer
camps before i was uh seven years old
and i got to spend eight weeks
in whatever location it was as a kid
that had no obligations just
experiencing all the fun
so cool summer camp
so i got to do
uh drama program
you know i was like an add-on they were
putting on a talent show
and they had created an interstitial
narrative thread that was like we're
star trek and we're traveling through
the galaxy and we're gonna look at all
these different performers on each of
these different planets and so they
thought it would be adorable to have the
two foot tall six year old
be the captain of the starship um
we're on our way to the intergalactic
interstellar bastion star point of 3.816
and we're going to see the the creative
duo of the twerkers
they thought that was hilarious and i
loved it until they started until you
started taking their good parts so wait
a minute he got hamlet too i did i did i
like improv some singers they like
looked at me
but i felt that i felt that thing where
the rush
i don't know how to explain it because
i've never been attracted to the
applause it's something different
it's something different for me where i
feel my highest vibration between action
and cut the same same exact in fact seth
i was just so funny you say that i i
feel not only highest vibration but
lately i would say it's simpler than
that to for me it's it's freedom it's a
sense of um
yeah it's the sense of freedom it's
really beautiful now we're all we're all
in it together man like the more actors
i work with the more i realize how
synonymous all of our idiosyncrasies or
our fears and insecurities really are
like the
the thing that we get to share is our
our love and our passion for the thing
and also the fact that we're all
a little [ __ ] crazy for wanting to do
this
yes yes well especially if if the
applause if that thing
is doesn't factor in you know if it's um
yeah if it's not part of the equation
because i think it is for a lot of kids
i think a lot of kids in high school
like to go out and oh this is the their
parents take photos and that's part of
it that's i think that's generational i
was actually just having this
conversation with a friend of mine you
know when i was growing up um
there were only a handful of people that
had a camera or a
film camera or even a video camera and
then
in the generations post the internet or
cell phone cameras every kid that grows
up
grows up with a scrutinized
documentation of every moment of their
life and instead of just holy [ __ ] i
can't believe we captured
baby's first steps
you have an entire instagram or facebook
account dedicated to the evolution of
this character so how deconstructive is
that for the child themselves but
separate from that i just think there's
two different kinds of people there's
people that really want the attention
and then there's people that need
to do this thing and there's a lot of
then diagram crossover between the two
but i i don't know
i'm the
the latter i guess
i'll tell you yeah an interesting thing
that i can't remember if i told this out
to honor or not but
the only time i've gotten to do like a
long run of a play i got to do 42
performances of american buffalo dan
floric uh was the actor that was in this
play with him and john mcmurtry and dan
i'd never i just never done it before
and i had you know six weeks of
rehearsal and then we started putting
the show up and
it was it was the most incredible
experience i'd ever had as an actor i
really truly loved it but we came out
like three
performances in a row i think i was 22
maybe and so uncomfortable
with myself in my skin still like very
very awkward and really a little bit
yeah and uh dan
noticed me like taking sort of
apprehensive vows and when we got off
stage he grabbed me by this children
what are you doing out there
and i go what do you mean he goes that
curtain call this like
[ __ ] you what are you doing and i was
like
what do you mean and i'll never forget
this he goes that's not for you
that's for the audience
i was like oh my god okay
okay that would stick with me that's
that i'm gonna remember that it did
stick with me i got another piece of
advice that was um i'll leave the names
a little ambiguous so it's not as much
of a direct thing but i it worked on a
movie where
we it was a lot of uh stars and we had a
scene with a ton of extras and as a
result the ad
um introduced each of the people in the
cast to the extras as i like and here's
this person right so that everybody felt
like they were a part of it we all like
waved and then went we all did the scene
again
uh one of the actors
really hammed up his introduction all
right hold on i'm sorry to hear the
story without
i i'm only thinking about can't hardly
wait and i don't want to know who it is
because i'm assuming that's what it is
it's not but uh i would deny everything
i'll tell you offline okay all right
okay okay i'm sorry so i'm i'm liking
that we've all come out we've waved our
thing and we're all like huddled and
then one of the actors comes out and
does like a big hamming it up like takes
an extra spin or something and um
one of the other actors has been in it
forever his shoulder shoulder with me
and says
you see that he needs it and then looks
me in the eye looks me in the eye and
says
you can't need it oh that's great so
that that's great that hit me that's
over 20 years ago too so i've had the
benefit of other people
being kind enough
to
grab me when i'm [ __ ] up give me a
gentle corrections i'm so curious it was
um see this is why i'm such a yenta i'm
so like gossipy and like i just want to
know who it was it's such a valuable
story it doesn't matter who it was
justin and don't speak in the third
person um
oh that that play now american but had
you was it um the type of experience
that you wanted to recreate like did you
then want to do more plays and i did but
that was the same summer that i did the
first austin powers
and so i had a completely different
series of opportunities for the next
several years
i talked to to my
manager um
like three or four years ago and i said
i really wanna i need
i've been i've been um
doing so much producing
um and like behind the scenes
development i was like i really just
need to act in something i really just
need to
stretch that muscle because that's where
i feel the most
that's where i feel the most myself so i
love nurturing yeah and when i don't
i spend time
not taking it for granted but not
nurturing it the way that i typically do
if i'm if i'm gonna be performing in
something i feel it in every animal my
body
how does that manifest itself do you get
more irritable do you get like do you
start climbing the walls i just need to
become sort of creatively uninspired
there's so much of producing is
mechanical work um so much of
getting something from script to screen
is is really just
labor-intensive mechanical work it's
things have to happen at a certain time
to fit within your budget to make all of
your deadlines and as a producer i'm
really conscious of making sure that
everybody has what they need to be able
to do their job to the best of their
ability like i really take serious the
notion of teamwork and every single
person
not only needing to be their best but
being given the tools with which to be
their best that's the only way you get
the perfect thing
yes seth and i you strike me as somebody
who has
when you do the other job when you are
an actor only on something you strike me
as somebody who has a great
work ethic like a really dedicated
work ethic and um
and it's so it's the way i try to be and
it it really bothers me when
i work with people especially in that
capacity you're talking about where it's
the few things i've done
producer-wise or as a director
you got to do a [ __ ] die-hard movie
come on man that's like as big as it
gets yeah yeah well well yeah we should
talk about but you've done the big ones
and like you see that when people aren't
working the way you are when they aren't
um
employing the same kind of work ethic
it always frustrates me i always get
really
you know it's it's tough especially when
you're talking about producing and it
must be you must be more conscientious
of it of people's limitations and well i
grew up as a sporting performer you know
almost all of the work that i did
especially at the beginning were i've
only had a handful of what you call a
starring role and so my job by and large
has been in the role of supporting
performers what that means to me is to
provide support like to be excellent
without question to take any direction
or be able to roll with any technical
punches but also
to
graciously and generously support
the leads um
and through my whole career
because i've played like the best friend
or the quirky cousin or like the guy
that the girl doesn't want to date all
of my
scenes are
in service to making them shine and so
whenever i've worked with a lead who
has a fundamentally different process
than me
i do all my process in the margins so
that when i'm there i'm supporting their
process
and that
me
a very
attentive director
um and especially because i grew up
as a kid working on all this stuff i was
really presented over and over again for
over 20 years with the reality that
everyone on set is
important there is no one person who is
more important than the other and we are
all working together to provide the
correct circumstances so that the job
gets done on time and most actors are
barely conscious about how their gift
works
right
and in a lot of cases they've followed
something passionately but they've also
stumbled into a [ __ ] landmine field
of potential problems disturbances or
all this stuff um
so when i'm
especially when i'm directing i'm really
conscious about how it feels
to be an actor how much
doubt and insecurity and no matter how
hard you've worked when they call action
you're like is it enough is it enough um
and so i always try and just as a
director create the environments of the
actor can give me their thing
you know as pure and as fearlessly as
possible and it must be just navigating
personalities too because the same as
being a supporting actor it's just oh
how do i how do i support this person uh
because they have a different process
that you mentioned die hard like that's
a perfect example we had totally
different
approaches i think i remember the most
about that don't you guys drive a police
car into a helicopter at one point
yes i i don't i he pushes me out or
something i'm like go bruce yeah i
remember that was one of the things set
that where they said they needed they
wanted apparently they had like these
stunts
that were
um agreed upon or maybe written out in
some form before they wrote the script
and so this script became about how do
we get from like the helicopter thing to
like him on the jet at the end you know
it it just became about this how do we
get to these stunts and um
so the studio and i'm sure you've had
this experience with where the studio
was very
they were very open to they came and
like really encouraged me to improvise
because there was
it was their way of saying i think you
know we hadn't considered the dialogue
as much
you know so
so do whatever you feel like and len the
director was really like into
playing around but
bruce wasn't i mean it was just as
simple as that some actors you know i
mean talking about supporting act i i i
came up the same way and it's
if somebody's not into that um you got
to make adjustments and
so there were times i shot a lot of my
stuff with his body double because um
yeah
you know he just we just worked
but in a way
when you're allowed that freedom i've
had some magical experiences in those
circumstances the best example of um
getting to film my coverage
after everybody else was gone was on
entourage um we had this scene
when we were we were filming it was the
it was the episode where we're all in
vegas and
um it was julian who directed it he was
so cool about like just drift on it and
um
he let me uh throw a couple of lines uh
they turned around so they could set up
the other scene and all the other guys
went to block their stuff and they just
left a camera and a couple of extras in
me and i just started throwing out a
bunch of [ __ ] and that's where that um
uh jackson pollock line came from the
whole backstory was this idea because
you were you you were with sloane you
had dated sloane yes
that was it was it was ambiguous but um
imagine ambiguous
and kevin and i uh with doug ellen came
up with what we believe the story is and
that it gives it gives a lot of um
personality justification uh for for
everybody i liked that because it was
both really filthy but also
quasi-intellectual like
it's disgusting but also wow this guy's
got a perspective on modern art
yeah
yeah exactly which is also threatening
because like kevin can't just be
threatened by you because you may have
hooked up with you know there are other
things like you're successful and you
are you know you're you're a bit
cultured
it's such a great character and that's
right now that you mentioned it
it makes sense that you guys were yeah
came up at the same time um i remember i
started to see you i think we're around
the same age but i would see you guys
and things um around then were you
always in the waiting rooms together do
you remember that's how you met you met
just as like two young actors yeah we we
um we always saw each other okay he was
out of long island i think long island
or stat i think it was long island um
and i was out of philadelphia but we
always saw each other in auditions in
new york and then when we were seven
years old we did a
commercial for the matchbox car wash
oh my god i remember i loved those
like a saturday morning
commercial yeah were you guys playing
with the matchboxes
oh man i always i i always wonder how
how uh what is they just have a thing
set up so they let you
they let you play around just okay no
it's very specific we like to push the
car through
and then we ride it wind it through the
dryer
and then i score it in the water they do
close-ups of it we do the whole thing
it's like hey jimmy's here let's go wash
our cars
so
and i know you know a lot of people
outside the business but you do have a
good group of actor friends and um
whenever i work with them or cross paths
with them you know they they i always
enjoy hanging out with them i like your
crew i hear like uh ryan phillippe i
just got to work with and
i know you're close with brecken and do
you just gravitate toward people like
that do you is it is it as simple as
like uh yeah you know i've worked we
work together we get clothes i mean
sometimes i you you
one of my favorite experiences which is
also it really just speaks to the
transient nature of our business but i
love going on location and making a
movie with like over 100 people and
really becoming a family in that
experience all for the benefit of
creating this thing right and then you
all break at the end of it and
maybe you see each other maybe you never
see them again maybe you stay in touch
with one or two people that you really
had a
a real connection with or maybe you just
crossed paths every couple of years like
that's
that's my favorite thing about this
business is this sense of collecting
community right you don't get on with
everybody but
like i never went to college so
being in in la all of the kids that were
in my immediate orbit you know a kids my
age or kids that were growing up with a
similar experience like those are still
some of my closest friends well so seth
so can't hardly wait must have been like
the ultimate of that that must have been
like all of these
yeah yeah
what
you must have known a bunch of those
guys going in did you yeah everybody
knew each other we had all we'd all sort
of audition for each other's parts too
no kidding or did you get the one that
you wanted were you hoping to was that
the one that you were yeah yeah well
that uh i don't know if you know this
but uh that part was originally written
for bracken and then wrecking got that i
wonder the studio 54 movie with ryan and
couldn't do it
and so i didn't get cast deborah wrote
it right yeah exactly but i still had to
read for it and i still had to screen
test with three different actresses oh
my god that's funny no kidding
so lauren obviously got the part but it
was um yeah so she hadn't been cast oh
that's interesting i didn't know that
that makes sense though
i put everybody on camera i don't even
know if love was cast without reading oh
yeah forget people call her love she and
i did a show together when i
was 19 and she was 14.
and so that was how we met and that's
that's probably why i've always thought
about her it's like 35 uh no it was
called birds of paradise it was queen
party at five
um it was a show it was a bocco show on
abc very short-lived with uh tim
busfield oh my god ah yeah i know yeah
sethi yeah
i love busfield he was an older
oh god how great um i know he was my dad
oh yeah oh my god that makes sense
that's great you see [ __ ] master
yeah do you do do you have um i was
gonna ask you if you did an impression
of well certainly of uh woody i'm
curious if you have uh do you have
i never really worked on it like so many
other people i think the best one i ever
saw was edward norton's like his
woody is so [ __ ] flawless my favorite
thing is to try and capture
the the thing about the person so it's
less abound like dana carvey's
incredible at that he just finds
one detail and then stretches it to the
point where it's very very funny so like
when everybody when jay moore started
doing that chris walken on snl uh-huh
where he was like you know i've always
i've got this time
in my face
i started trying to workshop those
smaller details was like you know justin
i find you to be incredibly attractive
so you
should come over here
and i'll tell you what i need
like i like i like those i like i like
seductive walking
i also like complimentary walking
sometimes when i'm masturbating on the
toilet okay i think about you well
there's a happy medium
i remember auditioning for his wife once
and she was like i was all set to do the
impression
you know i told her i was a big fan of
her husband's
and just to set myself up for like an
impression she goes oh that's nice just
don't do the impression
and i'm like all right thank you so much
so dumb just to try to i got to work
with him uh one time and he was so
i don't know like you probably have the
same thing where you get the chance to
work with somebody and you just somebody
that you like yeah you just want to make
the right impression or yeah be able to
like be there so i i met him in the
trailer
and um i was like oh hey chris great to
meet you we're gonna be doing that uh
see you later i didn't know if you had
any any thoughts about it and he said
that you know i think that martians are
real
and i was like oh first thing out of his
mouth i was like
okay yeah that's plausible do you want
to do you want to run with that and he
was like there's things we don't know
there's so much we don't know and i was
like that's very fair that's cool so um
is this martian related was the movie at
all martian related no it was a movie
called america's sweethearts where um
the story is that billy crystal is a
press
he's the public the publicist for the
studio that's putting out the new john
cusack catherine zeta john's movie yeah
and the story is that they at one time
had been a glorious couple like they
hate each other and jennifer aniston and
now they hate each other yeah and it's
this um peter totally wrote the script
with billy it was such a dark script
um a very different movie oh really
really fun with all of these awesome
people i got to play uh so billy's
characters getting fired and i'm the
incoming publicist this like smarmy
super out of his depths like following
the studio line and like i'm sure all of
your creativity will be well respected
into the future and um i'm i'm instantly
over my head and need billy back on the
job to show me how to do it and so
uh chris walken plays the director of
the film and he's this incredibly
eccentric character steps off a
helicopter at one point with the film in
the metal box and he's like i'm not
giving this to anybody no one has this
film the first time anyone sees this
tonight not the show and
watkins playing an eccentric that's
funny it's what's more like um kevin
pollock's uh christopher walken
yeah and so um i have this scene with
him at the end and the the story is that
my character has had a total change of
heart like now is all about the art
wants to assure the commerce completely
and i say to him at the end of it i come
up to him i'm like i don't your film my
your film was
so moving to me i i wanna this is what i
wanna do i wanna work for you would you
please would you take me on as a as a
student
that's all the scene was supposed to huh
and uh and joe roth uh who directed the
movie was like you know just do whatever
you want and so
you know chris and i had only met in the
trailer i come up to the scene and he
doesn't say a word from and i go would
you would you take me on he doesn't say
a word for a minute then he goes you
know redheads are rare
and so
so if in in character i'm like yeah
yeah oh you stay yeah yes because it's
like maybe it's a real character yeah i
think this i'm like let's just run with
it yes yes we are and he goes it's
recessive
from the mother's side
oh no no he says bob is recessive from
the mother's side
and i said
your mother is bald and he just goes
like this
and that was all i needed i was like i
got you joe rothko's cut do they
that's in the movie oh it is
that one take is in the movie yeah
redheads what do you say redheads are
rare the red heads are rare
i love when he breathes through a line
like a word rare
that's so good
[Music]
this segment is brought to you by light
seltzer's new that's annoying voice yeah
i don't think they'll appreciate that
because it's not an annoying product
it's our friends bud light seltzer's new
retro summer pack throwback story i have
one i used to love one of my favorite
parts of the summer the sounds the
summer sounds it's something that i
think i appreciate more with each
passing year and the first chair in the
symphony of the summer would be frogs
the sound of frogs spring peepers oh
those spring peepers so ready for good
vibes this summer yeah bud light seltzer
is here to help you bring the good vibes
wherever you go
whether they're frogs they're not
with their new limited edition bud light
seltzer retro summer pack it's a new
tie-dye pack which features three
throwback flavors that remind me of
summer's gone by blue raspberry love
that flavor summer ice which tastes a
bit like the red white and blue popsicle
and cherry limeade delicious and
refreshing anyway the flavors slap if
that weren't exciting enough for the
first time ever fans can also purchase
these out of sight flavors in a new form
with bud light seltzer retro summer
icicles those are refreshing and the
same flavors so grab some friends not
aggressively play some tunes whatever
tunes you like and enjoy the vibes so
get it delivered right to your door find
a retailer near you at
budlight.com
delivery or what else can you do justin
uh you can go to your local neighborhood
grocery store convenience store whatever
liquor store pick it up
[Music]
you were around mike myers a lot he must
have told some great uh
stories about the snl days you must that
must have been a thrill to be around
that guy
it was a thrill yeah well i um by the
time we we did that first movie i was
such a fan of his both of the wayne's
world and um so i married an axe
murderer had already come out and
my first impression of him i came into
the trailer and he was getting his head
shaved to play dr evil and i was like oh
[ __ ] i thought i thought it was going to
be a bald cap or something and i was
like oh this level of commitment is
really impressive and so we like that
first day uh the first day that we
worked together we filmed that therapy
scene with carrie fisher and so he was
in the makeup the whole day and we had a
lot of time in between setups that we
were talking but i wasn't pressing him
for those kind of stories as much as we
were talking about this character
dynamic or what was fair game with
improv or
what we thought we were going to do and
then we talked a little bit about um his
his father had passed away pretty
recently and so we talked a bit about
that
um
but
we had very little
uh social interaction outside of the
work we just spent all this time in this
work together and he yeah you know i
just i just [ __ ] love the guy because
he was
so gracious
and generous to me like gave me
opportunities to shine endlessly and was
not
precious about this is my moment or
that whole crew that's why it was so fun
it felt like everybody could do whatever
oh
and as long as it was on the same topic
um it got in the movie did you have a
sense that what you were doing was like
potentially going to be
something that really lasted no no no
because
you know all of my fortune in making
things has
has been
you know lightning in a bottle itself so
most of the things that i've done have
actually failed or been cancelled or
didn't make money yeah or were released
independently and went straight to dvd
so i have only had
even though i've had like seemingly won
the lottery several times the bulk of my
experience consistently has not been um
successful and so psychologically you go
in with that mindset like well
i'm not there for what comes next we're
here for the thing you know what i mean
like we're gonna do our best to make
because i know that sometimes it's
it
you you never know the difference like
when we were making an italian job
nobody knew it was going to be a blowout
we thought it was cool
but you see so many things that are cool
not work um and we just happen to have
like a great combination of
a well-written plot with a really strong
director and then a group that was
assembled
in a way where we were having fun and
you could see it on film you had
mentioned the things that failed and
kind of becoming uh desensitized to to
the expectations and
what is what's an example of something
that you thought the opposite oh this is
surely gonna be
huge
i thought that disney movie mars needs
moms that i did was gonna get a better
receipt and it was an excellent
education in a lot of things that have
nothing to do with the product itself
there was a lot of studio politics i had
not realized there was
any kind of dynamic between
robert zemeckis's company at
disney
i didn't realize there was a competition
between pixar
and illumination i was unaware that
critics
across the world
decided that polar express didn't work
and they were going to continue to
chastise zemeckis for
what they perceived as some ludicrous
flight of fancy uh whereas you know bob
was just trying to make movies that he
was passionate about there was just a
lot of politics that i was unaware of
and when we went to the press junket the
way the like european press was savaging
zamekas who was sitting right there
talking about things that weren't true
like accusing polar express of being a
failure um saying that all of the
technology in the original movie created
these like dead-eyed uncanny valley and
not recognizing that the technology had
advanced
a thousand-fold by the time we were
putting this movie out
um so i thought that movie would do
better uh because it was so cool and
because i loved it and because i had
such a great time
making it and was was really not
surprised but disappointed that it
didn't catch on the way we hoped it
would well and at that point seth like
you had had enough experiences with
failure as you said but also with these
successes so like
you probably had it was you know uh it
was probably easier for you to determine
whether or not something might
hit uh well more more than anything i
have less of a
um emotional position about it
you know what i mean i'm not like oh man
that didn't work what the [ __ ] i'm i'm
bad at this or we blew it it's more like
[ __ ] i thought that would work all right
well let's let's try again and correct
me if i'm wrong but like the important
moments in your career was it can't
hardly wait austin powers was that
kind of interest
well that was when i mean that was when
everything i had this year where several
things converged and all of a sudden
everybody knew my name so even though i
had spent
um almost 20 years at that point
working and being known within the
industry but known the same way that
like richard jenkins or um
stanley tucci or david stravarin was
like i wasn't
known
but i was known within the industry and
i'd worked with everybody um so by the
time
austin powers came out on dvd and ken
early weight came out and i was made a
series regular on buffy that was all the
same year
and so in one
year everybody knew my name because you
would say austin powers it's funny you
said it when it came out on dvd it
wasn't a hit in the theaters right that
first one no it was actually
an incredibly independent movie that no
one was willing to finance and new line
finally got behind it i swear the budget
was less than 15 million dollars and
when it came out
nobody cared about it and then when it
came out on dvd
and everybody saw it it sold millions of
copies we were like holy [ __ ] people saw
that movie and you're happy because i
loved it i loved the movie i couldn't
believe how well it turned out like i
couldn't believe like that we pulled it
off and i felt i felt like like i'd won
the lottery just to get that part that
it
doing well became crazy icing oh hi
hello ah the big cat just drove oh thank
god that cat's huge
holy [ __ ]
what kind of cat is that it looks like a
um
seth's holding up a very fluffy
uh yellow
with she's a ragdoll
called molly hold on a second i'll give
you i'll give you the expand
oh my he's holding it
michelle will you take a picture of that
um hello sir ma'am
it's a beautiful cat she's a good one
god it's really affectionate
it was right in the foreground so it was
um
it looked even bigger than it is
come here look she's just traipsing back
and forth
does it is it affectionate
jesus we have we have uh two of this
breed
um and they are they are the best man
i've never i've had a lot of cats but
never had this breed before and they're
um
floppy uh but
active and incredibly cuddly and so
affectionate it's it's making me want um
to look at i'm allergic to cats so i
would have to do something about that
this breed doesn't have an undercoat so
if you're not allergic to the saliva you
won't be allergic to this breed
because
i developed an allergy to cats too late
in life and i've had to get shots and
take medicine literally every day
because we have another cat that is a um
a rescue and i'm incredibly allergic to
her but over the last 10 years i've
become
because i'm taking all this medicine now
i can like rub my face
a great relationship
did you just uh develop the allergy
because you were around it so much
around cat i don't know um i talked to
an allergist who said that kids that go
away to college for four years come back
allergic to their family cat
oh funny so sometimes you in the absence
of it i guess can develop an allergy i
had cats from the time i was 16
uh to the time i was like 23
and
and then i had several years where i
didn't have where i had i actually had
two dogs for a period of time
and a cat
but in that absence uh post the cat i
developed the allergy
seth was that a time where you were
living on your did you move out early
did you finish high school early and and
yeah yeah i am
yeah man when um
so when i was
16
actually i know exactly how this
happened so i made that mini series it
the year i turned 15
and then made plans to move out to la
the following year i've been coming to
la like over the summers or for pilot
season
for like a couple months at a time but i
was like
if i'm gonna be serious about doing this
job i have to be in california so i was
planning to move out uh when i was 16
and
that's what i did i got an apartment in
la
my room my first roommates were other
kids that worked on it
and then my mom moved out
the year i turned 18
and um
i lived in the apartment above me but
i did all of my school through
like remote
transfer and my school was just really
cool in philadelphia they let me
you know do this continuing school in
los angeles and then um transfer all of
my transcripts so i was able to walk
with my class in philadelphia
so you were close with so the what were
the kids how socially how did they treat
you after you were in these movies and
things that
because it's not like l.a or new york
where like a lot of there are other kids
who are
like brecken the way brecken grew up
like he was one of you know
um
this town must have been unique
yeah yeah i was i was already
i had a really difficult time
socializing um
i had so much energy and i i really
wanted people to like me
and um
um
yeah right so by the time i was eight
i was
before i started acting professionally
just at my school i was one of three
jewish kids i was one of five redheads
um and i was one of the shortest people
in my class uh for my age
and so
all of those things separated me and i
was hyper and i was constantly doing
voices and uh always trying to perform
and uh people did not like me and then
the second i started working
professionally
i got both sides of it where
if i
put myself out there and tried to be
friends with anybody everybody accused
me of thinking i was so special because
uh i'm an actor
and
if i was like jealousy some jealousy
just a misinterpretation and then if i
was quiet and kept to myself and didn't
try to
be friends with anyone i was accused of
being stuck up because i was an actor
and so i rode that from the time i was
eight to the time i graduated like
everywhere and i tried to
make friends at school but it became
really obvious to me um especially as i
started working more in my chosen field
that that was my peer group and it
wasn't that
i had to change to fit in at school it
was that i just belonged somewhere else
you just fit in you felt comfortable you
felt safe with those people in a way
that you did yeah i was like oh this is
this is
obviously the same
way of thinking that i have the type of
priorities and goals that i have well i
realized i think i told you this like
we technically known each other for so
long but this is hands down the longest
conversation we've heard yes well it's
funny it's funny because i was listening
to you talk to anna and i was like well
that's surprising you had said a similar
thing you guys were like yeah we've
known of one another and we kind of been
in i mean i've been around you we've
we've chatted but i do remember seeing
you a lot at uh
at the 70s show is am i is that am i
mistaken no no you're right it was um
that crazy time in reality where so i
had um
i've known danny masterson out of new
york growing up
and then
mila and i were on family guy together
from the time she was 14. oh that's
right and so
i knew a bunch of the writers on 70s and
when
when that show was really going
they um
they just had a ton of guests it was on
radford which i spent my life working on
and um and so we would just come on
friday nights when the show was taping
and it would be like a hangout and then
uh a gang of kids would go to one of
these dance clubs on after the show and
just go dance all night it was really
awesome it's the only time i've ever had
that kind of experience in my life um
where i knew everybody and we would all
show up at a club and the club was a
safe place to be and you could just
dance and you didn't have to drink
didn't have to like try and hook up with
somebody you could really just go and
sort of shake the week off and it was
very very awesome it was awesome so i
was there all the time i i saw you there
a bunch we hung out a bunch i i really
enjoyed it because it was it was like um
it was also a rare social hub like that
where it was a bunch of actors who knew
each other um
i think i was there because i got to
know wilmer a little bit when i was
working with lindsey
yeah it was just a fun
and people like i
admired and it was a good time i was
talking to sarah pantera her name comes
up a lot pantera sarah
because because she was like
you know the hub of she was the
uh you know where everyone she knew
everyone and and
powerful force yeah but i i so seldom go
out that um
now it seems doesn't it that time seem
like such a
distance it feels like another another
light like it's actually impossible for
any of the people
that are our age to recapture
the magic of that experience because it
was it was partially based on the age
that we were at like what we were
discovering about ourselves and how we
were sort of being defined and also you
know clubs were a much
different uh idea before all of the
promoters became reality stars and
you know the the clubs themselves were a
fixture in something like entourage like
it fundamentally changes the way
i think you you're able to access it so
i'm grateful that we got
that at that time that safe and
protected like
let loose experience doesn't feel
available in the same ways i know what's
funny seth when i met you i was
surprised and i hate saying this because
it's like oh you don't want to give off
an unfriendly not that you were i'm
surprised by how friendly you were but
like
i just i i think it was whatever
perception i had of you i i it was
clearly from
them it must have been from scott evil
or i don't know
it must have been from that whatever
you i was in my head about you i was
like i just remember being very
surprised which i shouldn't have been
by how friendly and easygoing you were
um
i guess i i don't know did you have a
perception of that like how people saw
you just as a public person
i mean i'm not i'm not without awareness
of the different types of things that
people throw back at me or
what impression i could be giving but i
i try really hard i try really hard not
to focus on that um because all those
things can make can make me at least
very insecure
um
if i if i really try and out think um
what someone else is thinking and then
try and shape myself in response to that
i find that i'm the most
um
awkward and weird and uncomfortable and
i can i can see
when people are put off by my own
insecurity so i try really hard not to
ever let myself get to a place where
that's what i'm projecting and is your
wife in the in the business yeah she's
an actress and a producer
claire craig i know i've met your wife
i'm an idiot i've met claire but what's
funny is that um this is actually my
favorite thing about us being married is
that nobody
remembers that we're married and when
people see us together because she's
taller than me
people can't
like work it out um
they can't do the math um
i'm like this is great because people
will automatically go to this and we'll
never have to be a tabloid sensation
like the only thing they'll be able to
talk about is like he's so sure she's
gone how does this work and i'm like
this this will be our this will be our
uh our our our flash pops right we just
throw those down the aisle and no one's
gonna no one's ever gonna pay any
attention to our real life oh look at
him oh that's another one okay so that's
artemis yeah god they're huge
is putting it around like a like a
a hunter like a you're wearing it like a
like a mink like a like a like a fine
stall yeah yeah wow there's they look so
soft they're really fluffy it's fluffy
so they don't shed you don't get all
that shedding nonsense he doesn't shed
as bad as she does they're they're
different um colorings of the same breed
and uh she needs to get brushed all the
time she's like a fluffball it's insane
so are you still taking the [ __ ] to
combat your allergies or are they they
gone or you don't have that cat anymore
uh well no i still have that cat um and
um
yes i still make i take medicine twice a
day and i still get the shots every
month
uh i mean i don't want to tell you how
to live your life you figured it out
you're doing great but yeah the things
we do for love right i'm guessing claire
was really into the cats originally yeah
the the cat that i'm most allergic to is
a cat that she had before we met and she
had another cat when we met that that
ran away uh sadly but but he was um i
was terribly allergic to him but i was
also in love with him so
i started taking the meds just to be
able to hang out with him wow that's
love that isn't that one of those it's
one of those litmus tests right where
like you know you really like somebody
but how long have you been together uh
we've been married 10 years we've been
together um 12 i think wow wow 10 years
um
yeah i know we did a movie together so
earlier today i was looking at your
movies do you know what it was i wonder
if you know because you've done so many
no
well because we know we haven't really
gotten to do stuff to together were we
in the same movie that's funny i should
have looked at this
it was well i had not re i didn't
because it's also not a movie that i
think often about um and you i wonder if
you're the same
it's called old dogs of course
first of all i love that movie it was
like one of the most well kind of i've
met rob williams a couple of times i'm
treating the same way he was
such a profound influence on me in so
many different ways that getting to meet
him and especially getting to do that
movie with him it was one of the most
gratifying experiences i've ever had
just getting to like come to work every
day and do scenes with him um and i'd
already made three movies with john
travolta so us getting to like be back
in the same place together with somebody
oh my god this is very funny so he was
um i got to do a movie called white
man's burden i came in as a photo double
for jason christopher and so i met john
then and then he's in um the
second dos or the third austin powers
i guess and then
um be cool
um oh you did another movie like gary
that gary directed he was like come play
this video director and do a scene with
john i was like absolutely absolutely oh
yeah oh yeah they were
but that movie um
bulldogs like they kept
um filling every role with somebody
awesome
um so even like the littlest overall was
like somebody else it was fun i mean it
was just to be around like you said
robin williams just uh and travolta and
matt dillon i got who i loved um
but what was your what was your
experience with robin like i'm curious
it was i mean it was it was incredible
the first day that i was there we were
doing uh the scene where we're around
the table with all of these chinese
investors and we're trying to sell our
company to this company the very first
thing that robin said to me when i got
on set he was like robot chicken
and i
oh your heart must have stopped it did
it just stopped on site yeah and i was
like oh you like our show and he goes i
love your show and i'm like i'm gonna
swag the [ __ ] out of you
you know you're like okay green light
you got it i sent you you'll be sorry
you did that i told him i gave him every
dvd we had i gave him like three
different season hoodies we had i was
like here's everything please thank you
for loving her oh well not only that
seth but it like gives you the green
light it gives you total license then to
be like okay where do i begin with you
like i love all of your your [ __ ] i came
at him um
i was like what have you already been
working on in this scene how can i how
can i help and what's what's fair game
like do you want to like riff this do
you want to and it was it was incredible
that first day
we just between the three of us like
ripped so hard on all of our coverage
that it was like
it's incredible didn't it seem like he
had he was he had so much he found so
much joy in that like there i remember
thinking
god it seems like he i hope i
love it as much as he does um
when i'm his age like he just seemed
like he loved it like i found out um
retroactively a lot of what he was going
through um uh with the um the disease
that he had uh involved with you have
you seen that doc that his uh no
his
wife made
i don't know
but a lot of those things make more
sense like in between scenes
he would
do sudoku uh or sudoku he was doing all
kinds of brain games um in between every
scene he would like sit and do all these
brain games
to keep himself sharp yeah
yeah and apparently the way the disease
works he was struggling against not just
the disease and the way it sort of
twists your mentality the way it
corrupts your interpretation but also
the effects of the medicine that he was
taking to combat it were slowing him
and making him a little less lucid so
i had no idea obviously oh yeah i had no
idea i just remember him being so
playful in between takes
i thought it was so cool i thought it
was so like gracious and and um
generous with that he was doing the the
uh like popeye and mrs doubtfire he was
doing all his iconic characters for the
crew for extra he's got zero ego and
yeah
um he's one of those people who
regardless of how sad
he was because he understood the weight
of that sadness in people
he seemed
permanently dedicated to making people
smile i'm so grateful for it life could
be a dream
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and would
shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
when you're texting i don't know if you
use a lot of emojis but what would you
say is your most commonly used one like
you go to it's first
it's probably that either a heart or
the the happy face that's like
everything's fine with the hands up no
no not the heads up but the one that's
like so it's like it's mine too
everything's cool
yes yeah everything's fine and it's it's
slightly bowed
it's a little like lowered it's a little
differential but it's it's not it's not
giddy it's not aggressive it's not like
yes
yeah okay
me too a lot of similarities you also
unfortunately i wish i could you've
always been able to grow such a great
beard you have such great uh full beard
full ginger beard you can you can think
about me when you're reaching that top
shelf
well
if you could be a professional athlete
what sport would you play oh man i would
love to be able to play basketball um
but not only am i bad at the sport but i
don't know if you've noticed i'm not
very tall so um most of my effort
involves passing to somebody that can
shoot the ball you're taller than muggsy
bogues i think i think i have those hops
though i mean i can i can hop pretty
good but were you self-conscious about
that about your height ever when you
were growing up not really
self-conscious about it in the ways
where it precluded me from doing some
things but also it made me more
inventive to figure out how i can do
other things it never was an issue for
me as far as
confidence
or talking to
girls probably supplemented
uh any of that that lack of um
height for you know a
a better personality if you could have
one snack food for the rest of your life
what would it be um it's probably spicy
nacho doritos spicy huh you know i got
all the doritos that i eat and i don't
think i've ever had the spicy ones it's
the most true to the original dorito
flavor it just has a little bit extra
spice to it any other one is sort of a
variant on the dorito flavor it's not
like i don't love coral ranch or things
like that yeah but one of my most
sincere trigger foods that i've actually
um i don't i don't eat doritos and let's
say i used to eat like two balls of
doritos
you don't even have to you don't need it
anymore just would you
stop buying them like we'll only buy
them on
a special occasion or for a party and
then i'll just like i'll kill the whole
yeah yeah
it was was part was it was it like a
bigger dietary thing that you were doing
like an overhaul or or was it
specifically like you know that you
don't trust yourself around doritos well
i know for a fact it's a trigger food
but but also it was part of a larger hey
maybe i've gotta stop taking in so much
salt or so much processed things i've
gotta try it all around as i get older
to eat healthier yeah me too we're
trying what would you say uh is your
favorite movie sequel of all time what's
a movie sequel that you could just uh i
guess i could say empire strikes back
yeah because it's the it's it's one of
my favorite films and it's also an
incredibly effective sequel um but you
saw it in theaters
yeah yeah yeah i've seen i've seen the
incredible examples of the the second
movie
besting the first like i thought adam's
family values is way better than adam's
family um
and even to be self-referential like
awesome powers
it's like is a better more realized
version of the movement than the first
one
yeah yeah i and i've noticed it's on a
lot more um but
i love that first movie but i agree yeah
that second one is tough to be i just
realized um um last crusade is hands
down the best indiana jones movie ever
and yeah true far better sequel than the
original yeah i saw it recently and it
whole i was like because sometimes i
like to go back and revisit i wonder how
it holds up it really does it's yeah
once you get around the idea that
indiana jones is
not just a womanizer but
almost sort of aggressively never lets a
woman have her own way in the movies
then then it is
a forgivably excellent film
uh what's your go-to karaoke song i
imagine you like a good karaoke
um it changes it changes like um i've
had success with richie and superfruit
um
i've had success with uh islands in the
stream oh okay yeah andy rogers in dolly
parton i'm picturing yeah you and
donald's singing that now for some
reason
yeah i don't know i like karaoke yeah um
what is your who was your first most of
most of my go-to karaoke is right oh oh
oh interesting
yeah what what what like old school
stuff like uh rundee like dre like jay-z
um
you know anything that's that's not
too offensive right
yeah you gotta
you have to sort of self-censor or
replace your vocabulary or do that thing
on the on the radio where they gotta
is that a cat or a person
that was that was clear
that was like oh come on she's like why
why she's being so shy
i don't know hey claire
do you want to say hi to justin well
don't don't now it's like a claire where
how are you doing good how are you i'm
good why are you being so shy
me you didn't want to interrupt um yeah
yeah um can i see something about your
sneeze from earlier
did you hear me sneeze earlier
yeah but it was
it was aggressive it was that a typical
sneeze
um yeah
i typically do everything aggressive
wait
claire i also want to get your thoughts
on um
seth having taken uh medication for his
cat allergy in order to be with you
um i
i mean
i'm just never gonna get rid of my cat
so i feel like
it was a deal breaker
yeah but was that i mean
it was his
choice
um
so it's good were you ready
were you really appreciative
yeah i i was because i my cats were very
used to like sleeping with me at night
in the first several years that we were
together
once we figured out that he was allergic
to the cats they weren't allowed in our
bedroom anymore and so they would
literally sit on the other side of the
closed door and
haul and cry
which was heartbreaking i've heard that
i've heard a cat do that
an ex of mine had that like
they sound like kind of human
yeah
yeah
what um what happens to you seth do you
break out in hives
i wish it was that simple no um i
literally start uh choking on an
overproduction of mucus which is really
attractive and uh i would wake up in the
middle of the night unable to breathe
and think that i was
having
i thought i was just sick because i was
so used to getting sinus infections and
things like that yeah oh that's what it
was and the doctor was like no you're
you're activating all of your allergies
and and at that point how long had you
guys been together was it like oh [ __ ] i
like this that's too i can't back out
the first year we were together like
every day we were just friends really um
yeah
every day
yeah
was their tension or was it just like
you were with other
no it wasn't yeah
we actually had both just gotten out of
relationships but when we first met we
were both in other relationships and
then when we first started hanging out
i think even
when we were hanging out at comic-con
right you still yeah i was still yeah i
was still involved i was like
yeah i was still involved
we just weren't thinking about each
other in that in that way that's the
really only problem that's the best
that's the best way to get to out you're
so i mean i hear that a lot like um
because you have a foundation then
yeah yeah we also the thing i
i noticed the most was that because we
were hanging out as friends and not
trying to seduce each other yeah we were
incredibly forthcoming
yes
yeah so everything that we were saying
was like oh this is actually the truth
and at the by the time we were
romantic with each other we had such a
foundation of trust and comfort totally
that's so great and rare that's so nice
so then at that point it's like oh man
so i'm allergic to cats i got to figure
it out
claire maybe you can help answer the
rest of this lightning round um who was
his first celebrity crush
actually i do know this um
it was uh i have a guest [ __ ] well maybe
because we were talking about her but my
guess would be carrie fisher it's not
bad my guess is um
judy from actually oh i love tutti
what me too i gotta be tutti
i met kim fields and i had to really
like
keep it together
because it doesn't go away weirdly i i
found oh every time i run into her now i
feel like i've done a good job of like
keeping keeping cool well kim
is a
an avid listener of the show
so no i don't know
um
uh i i wish
what would you say seth that's not i
mean that's not a bad one i
because i was like eight
seven or eight when i saw e.t oh i was
crazy drew barrymore and i got to do an
episode of amazing stories and she knew
the director so she came to visit one
day when i was like nine years old i got
to have lunch with her and hang out and
i was super i was super into her by the
time we were teenagers knowing each
other that was
so unrealistic that i think i'd let it
dissolve you know it's you know you know
that it's brecken's first kiss or maybe
her
yeah
i remember
i think it was both of their first kids
i think so i think so did brecken ever
tell you about how pissed he was that i
i [ __ ] blocked him from michael keaton
on herbie yeah he did yeah
yeah he was mad right he was genuinely
mad
the only reason he had done that movie
was to like
i know i didn't know this at the time so
claire we're working with michael keaton
for like a solid four months he was on
it and and
i say this only because brecken had
ample opportunity when i wasn't even
around to like tell him how he felt
about it
so we're watching the i think it was the
carry the presidential debates this how
long ago was it was like
2004 debates and um michael it was his
last day and he stayed around to watch
and
one of the pas was like oh michael's
leaving if you want to say goodbye to
him and you know and i was like oh yeah
i want to say you know it's so nice
working with him so i
went out to meet him from this area we'd
all been watching in
and he was talking to brecken
and i didn't i was just like sorry
interrupt i just want to tell you my
michael great working whatever
and so michael's like yeah thanks and he
he was like by the way my son is doing a
is in a band here's his number what
so brecken and i so michael took his car
and brady and i got in a van
and um
and we're riding
for like maybe a minute and breaking's
like silent
and um one of the makeup ladies go he
goes she's like so bracken did you get
to did you get to tell michael how you
you know goodbye and and he goes
yeah i tried to but then [ __ ]
cockblock over here
interrupted
and he points to me and i
thought he was joking so i was like oh
sorry and he was like dude i'm
i'm serious and i realized he was
serious and um
what a rare serious moment i know well
that's the other thing is we have been
joking around so much it was he on that
set was i loved when he was at work
because like i really needed a you know
a buddy on that um
on that job and and um
so
so he left and and the makeup people
were like yeah you know he i didn't know
he named his kid keaton
he was that big a fan and um
so years later i i think we had we had a
laugh about it but um
he was he was he was and i was just like
brecken why didn't you just say
how you had felt about i didn't know you
were doing this whole
you know thing with him i didn't know i
interrupted that
i would probably be better for not
having been as dedicated that's what i
that's what i said and thought i was
like you know god forbid you like gushed
and made it weird with him and then he
bragging goes when he was like yeah [ __ ]
black over here and he got his number
he he got his son's number or something
on it yeah
um okay sorry i'm i'm monopolizing this
if you had to get a tattoo where would
you get it what would it be of do you
think oh he's definitely a [ __ ] stamp
guy
yeah
an asian symbol it would be a big all
access
and then an arrow on the front or the
back okay i have like five tattoos oh
you do what's uh what what's the so so
getting another one isn't that big of a
deal but what would it
or would it be
every tattoo i've gotten has been a real
moment in time like well like a
particular thing that happened and it's
i don't mind leaving um a road map of
experience i like that yeah
what was the first one seth
uh the first one i got it's uh on my arm
and it was a uh when i moved to l.a one
of my best friends gave me this necklace
with a sigil on it
and uh he was like this will protect you
on your travels and uh it was such a
meaningful gesture from a very close
friend before i left but i got it
tattooed uh on me um and then
the next thing i got was an icon from a
book i had loved and then what was that
what
uh herman hess the steppenwolf i read it
when i was 17
[Music]
impression of me and i love the the
artist drawing on the the edition that i
got so i got that tattoo cool and then i
read another book
called hope for the flowers that was
really inspiring about you know life and
choices and things like that pursuits in
different directions so i got that
tattooed
and then um
i got another one from a comic that i
loved growing up and then when we were
in thailand um i got the five lines on
my back which are the the most sacred
prayers of the book oh that's cool wait
wow and what would the next one be
my name
yeah important moments
in like 42 fonts that's what i'm saying
it's right just a big clear head on your
back
or your face or right on your face
yeah what's your favorite fruit what if
you
you could have a nice right piece of
well like a good apple yeah
apple comes up a lot honey crisp i had a
great honeycrisp the other day
they should be a sponsor um
who would you want to play you in in the
biopic in the seth green biopic
you know what's funny
you have to be somebody current like i
can't i can't uh i can't say danny
montegucci or david faustino ed asner
i'm a pagoda well you know what's funny
i'm like i'm realizing that this is a
it's a tricky question to ask an actor
especially like a relatively young actor
because it's like
i was talking to somebody that they're
dating they're like well me like i would
want to play me i don't want somebody
else to play me
i don't know i get that
question like any time um i've had
somebody
like we'll start talking a story and
they're like oh you should write a book
and i just don't
want to
that's the answer
what's your favorite simpsons character
oh man
it's probably um
uh isn't it ralph wiggum who's like uh i
sleep in a drawer yeah i choo choo
choose you yeah
i bet my wookie
yes yes
yeah that's funny uh the chiefs the
chief son who i incorrectly called um uh
martin i i thought it was martin but it
was um they're very different i was
embarrassed that i'd done that uh i know
this answer dogs are cats
um i i really actually just love
animals but we've got a we've got a nice
pack of cats right now so beetles are
the rolling stones
do you have a favorite song
i [ __ ] love the stones yeah i love
the stones love the stones but the
beatles were such a part of my actual
genetic makeup like my parents played my
mom had all the beatles records
including the original stuff from the
fan club and uh wow i played all that
stuff when i was growing up so i was
deeply entrenched in that would you have
a favorite song seth one that just has
associated with really good memories um
i love across the universe um
i love the ballad of john and yoko yeah
me too those are two of my favorites
yeah that's not amazing man we have a
lot in common we do actually there's so
many crossovers i i haven't wanted to
stop and say it every time because this
is not about me or it shouldn't be about
me but i'm like so many times like yeah
same
uh the seinfeld and friends they're both
on they're both on tv which one do you
watch i guess i watch seinfeld but the
the real truth and i hate to even admit
this is that i have not seen
all of either of those shows oh those
were both on at a time when i was
working more than i was watching and so
i saw like an average of a couple of
each of them or i know certain real
zeitgeist moments in each of them but i
didn't study them the way i watched
something like cheers
in night court like i watched those in a
different way and what about golden
girls because we used to ask who which
golden girl would you be uh dorothy
blanche rose or sophia
so fine you're having this conversation
the other night um
and i realized that at different points
i've been
each of them yeah yeah mix
i love the um the sexual confidence of
blanche i love the
um world weary cynicism of dorothy
i love the optimistic um empathetic
naivete of rose and i love to be
the whip cracking go [ __ ] yourself
sophia yes yeah what a great breakdown
oh man
claire just said seth sophia a very
you said that very definitively we have
a uh watched uh sketch coming up in the
new season
um
that is our it's our second golden girls
sketch the first one we did was golden
girl sex in the city
you know it went darker it went darker
and grosser than we ever anticipated
um
but the new one is more of a uh a space
adventure let's say that oh that's funny
what season is this
11. oh my god wow
i well i want to see your movie
changeland it's on hulu
right
and um i want to check it out because
it's got a hell of a cast and i i just i
really am such a fan of yours buddy i'm
so glad we got to do this oh it's mutual
yeah well when this when this whole
thing uh when we're allowed to see each
other in person again we'll get get some
coffee that'd be great and the cats i'll
make i'll i could i'll borrow some of
your allergy medicine
okay i'll get you the hazmat gear you've
got all the ppe you need thanks buddy
thanks that
[Music]
so
that happened that happened yeah a
little bit mischievous he's got like a
playful that's more kevin connolly yeah
yeah who he uh is friends with that's
right they're both um similar yeah
they're they're great together on
entourage really funny that's a funny um
runner
yeah it is we're we're seth plays like
and i i when i saw that i don't remember
having seen
that i'm sure it had been done before
but now it's like a really common device
to have like actors playing douchey
versions of themselves yeah you know but
that was i got a little played out that
did i
yeah at the end of the conversation he
was like you know we actually have a lot
in common you finally and i was waiting
for one of you to point that out yeah we
do because you really do you're you have
you're very similar in a lot of ways and
i realized some some of it might be
because
you're both
short growing up and like he said yeah
because he was short he had to develop a
certain kind of personality and you have
to
maybe overcompensate a little bit when
you're short and uh charm people in
other ways then the traditional ways and
you though you're not short now
you were short for a very long time i
think you were short when you were
developing your personality that's fair
to say right uh yeah for sure in fact
for short uh in fact sometimes i find
myself when i'm around tall people
i find that i'm weirdly more comfortable
sometimes like if i'm around basketball
players or like big bigger just because
it's it's something i'm used to it's a
dynamic i'm used to are you laughing
imagining me being around yeah it's
funny to imagine you at like a nba party
feel like being really comfortable well
i get really like jokey and deferential
i get i guess the way i probably was as
a kid i get really like playful it could
just be because it reminds you of being
a kid and you enjoyed being a kid sure
it might he seems like a grizzled
veteran of show business but he's only
in his 40s i know i know he's like he's
been around forever i know he even looks
kind of grizzled now because he's got
like a big beard and uh
yeah and he tells these stories about
showbiz like yeah you know sometimes we
do that bit where like in my day you
like pretend you have one of those like
cigarette holders like uh yeah i worked
with all of them yeah
uh yeah he is like that i mean not in
like a dirty way no no he has like
really good perspective i think kind of
like the baby i think so too but i think
that took a long time right but uh it's
your point i mean he's had a long time
to like learn those lessons and he's
like kevin connolly he is they they're
they're similar to me yes because
kevin's got like a real like adult um
energy he's got like a and confidence
and he was a good child actor remember
him on that show with the puppet
um yeah he was really good what was that
called happily ever after yes with um
who was the actress on that nikki cox
how does that why does that come to mind
so because i was very attracted to her
when i was a kid
so his wife joined at a certain point
the interview yes that's right uh and
that i found that cat stuff
so enjoyable
that he
had to get all he has to have like
monthly shots and he has to take i
medicine every day i know in order to
these cats in order to be around cats
it's kind of um but it's but at a
certain point you were like let me guess
she had the cat right when you started
dating yeah he was like yeah
yeah like oh okay way to bury the league
you had to do this to stay in the
relationship
it's not because you love cats right no
no no i know yeah he wasn't doing that
before just to like have cats yeah of
course that was uh i mean it was
probably like a who knows if it was a
deal breaker but i would imagine
i mean what what else do you do
because i've encountered this um
with cat with people i
you know ladies that i know who have
cats and um
i remember once um it was a real
deal breaker with a in fact i left my
favorite hat at this lady's house uh
because she and she had cats everywhere
uh-huh and i like what you're talking
about you do right yeah yeah like kind
of like the rockabilly lady yeah yeah
it wasn't at the point of in our
relationship where
one of us was going to go it was clear
who was going to go i think we both had
our share of um
bad pet experiences what was your worst
one
um you can't say it i can't say okay
oh now i really want to know well you
know
a bad pet when you're dating someone and
then they have a job
right yes yeah i can say it maggie had a
hey well
i think people know i think we're
typical yeah difficult yeah a
problematic pet
problematic pomeranian that's a funny
show
uh but he i love dogs he seems to have
uh really fallen in love with cats
though i think he really likes
pets so what does that mean i don't
think he's doing my point is i don't
think he's doing it strictly for the
real because he has to oh i'm sure i
think i think he's really oh he seemed
into it warmed up yeah oh he was excited
to show off the cats and like talk about
the cats no no he's a and and they don't
have kids so like those are their
i i i mean like when you're in a
relationship like i don't mind cats i
kind of like cats i i do too kind of
i've come you know both of you have come
around in cats recently
uh i do too because i met one
uh
when you describe meeting a pet as
meeting oh yeah i met a cat recently
who um they don't know you're they're
meeting you though a meeting has to be
mutual both parties need to know what's
happening oh really so if you run into a
wild animal you can't say yeah i guess
so so i encountered this cat in um
in my friend's cat in in la but it was
unlike any cat i've ever met or no or
like encountered been acquainted with it
yes it was so dog-like actually it like
it came right over and presented its
underbelly and like wanted like
affection
and it it kind of like
it had a demeanor of it more of a dog
than a cat wait you know cats kind of
like come and go
as they please i kind of like that thing
i know yeah they're much more
self-sufficient so seth green love lover
of pets uh-huh first celebrity christian
good pet owner yes first celebrity crush
drew barrymore yes and i don't think he
knew that you knew her the way you knew
her oh oh maybe not i got the impression
that he was just like yeah drew
barrymore oh yeah you're right you're
right i don't think he did there was no
sheepishness about that answer that he
gave you
that would have indicated like i know
this is weird but cause i know you dated
her that's true opposite of stamos
opposite of stamos
stamos has been telling me uh how how i
try how much he likes drew how
attractive now if you were still in a
relationship with drew that being that
would be not only insulting but
assaulting but not insulting but very
intimidating oh with samos don't you
think uh wouldn't you feel a little
nervous that stamos might try to swoop
in he's so handsome
yeah but here's the thing about drew is
that i don't think and this is to my
benefit i don't know that she's drawn to
like stereotypically attractive looks
aren't that important to her she would
have been with me right she can't be um
let's read a letter okay
this is from sarah norman
sarah with an h
sarah uh subject is sorry about an h at
the end
yeah sarah
sarah
sorry the subject is
sorry about your prostate exam
old school frowny face
isn't that funny that that's old school
it's funny that people know about your
prostate exam that they're writing
they're writing letters about you know
hi justin and christian greetings from
orlando
exclamation point that's why i said it
like that
my name's sarah i'm 18 and the person
who handles these letters is probably
sick of me writing in lol mish miesh are
you sick of this
um i began listening to the podcast
going to my senior year of high school
that's so cool
uh that's not what she said so i said
long story short life sucked for the
class of 2021
though i'll never be able to say i was
able to attend prom i am able to say
that i started crushing on justin long
in the middle of a pandemic which makes
for a much better story in my opinion
christian don't worry i love you too
thank you yeah i graduated in may and
since then i decided to take a gap year
to travel the world solo that is cool
solo wow that is so god i wish i had
done that also i i you didn't miss much
with prom
prom's not that great i know prom is not
that great it's
i know it's like it's a rite of passage
and all that but i don't know why
traveling the world is better than prom
back to sarah call me crazy but i'm
going to vegas soon i truly can't get
enough of the podcast and i've had so
many memorable experiences while
listening that's so nice sarah thank you
not to brag but i was but i was
listening to one of the quarantine
episodes when i got into my first car
accident it's funny oh god no it's funny
to wait but i hope it's not our fault
no in addition back to sarah in addition
i also listened to the paris hilton
episode on the way to my graduation
isn't it crazy to think that we're like
a part of yeah somebody's life like when
they're like big moments big moments
yeah you both are able to make me gush
giggle and smile for hours on end that
is really sweet turning the worst days
into brighter days one episode at the
time thank you well thank you sarah god
how nice to hear okay oh and the best
here we go sarah she knows what we like
would you rather always have to travel
alone
or always be accompanied by someone
travel yeah um sarah just took a year
off solo
um depends who the someone is yes uh but
if i could pick to someone yeah then i
would pick someone me too then i would
go with someone yeah but if i couldn't
pick with someone it was just a roll the
dice i'd i
wouldn't gamble on it and i'd go alone
because i like traveling alone too i do
too i did a cross country you don't
bother to like travel around i did a um
a cross-country amtrak trip by myself
that's right i'm so from la to new york
making a couple stops here and there but
i was all alone i met strangers along
the way i highly recommend that i wish
that's a really because also uh amtrak i
believe just
lowered the not a sponsor uh but could
be someday yeah just lowered the cost
for you get like a 15 day or 30 day rail
pass or maybe 10 days something like
that and you can get off get on and off
as many times as you want and it's like
200 bucks that's amazing and you can go
anywhere that's amazing it's such a i
wish i'd done a way to travel i bet i
love traveling by train you don't like
we both absolutely travel but did you
have a sleeper car no no i mean i a
little older now
a little more cash yeah a little more
cash flow i would probably do it that
way this time because that's i wonder
how much that's tough i know like
without because i remember i remember we
took a train remember this when we were
kids we took a train to visit grandma
and grandpa in florida and
that was a even for a kid i remember i i
was so
excited by it i remember like going
through i thought it was so cool that
everyone was sleeping on the train and i
was still awake you know and passing
through savannah and it would be like
we'd stop in these like cities i'd never
been in it was all dark it was so cool
childhood was fun it was um
good question though would you rather
yeah i would if i could pick i'd say the
same thing and um because the thought of
traveling now with someone
you know someone you like yeah so nice
sarah thank you uh and good luck on your
travels so does that mean she was class
of 2021 yeah i mean she just graduated
right yeah a few months ago so she's
beginning her gap year she's beginning
her solo chat i wonder where she's going
so uh i guess that's it for the show
right i guess so thanks uh to sarah and
everyone for listening and writing in
and if you want to write in oh yeah um
life is short at wondery.com thanks to
seth and to his lovely wife
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
uh life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted and co-produced by
you christian long also produced by
megan v monaco soon to have a child
megan v mother
producer is michelle miesh lans and the
audio engineer is sergio enriquez the
executive producer is marshall louis
it's a company called wandery
[Music]
you swat them away and they're just like
more determined to like be close to you
after that [ __ ]
[Music]
i know they don't they don't it doesn't
it doesn't like uh change their course
or anything they're not like oh [ __ ]
sorry for anything it makes them it
really does seem like they want want it
more yeah
to get it
what did you say that the if a mosquito
if that if it made that sound
it
made that sound but it was accompanied
by a but if it didn't bite and like a
firefly like a firefly made a mosquito
sound yeah
i would uh take that trade
and then if what if a fireflies like
stein you like a mosquito
um
i wouldn't like fireflies
you might still because like firefly
still the way they move it's like you
can see them you can see them they like
they're like blimps they just like kind
of hover i would i know but i'm like
picture i'm like imagining fireflies
singing or biting now and
i don't
just when i think about them as biting
creatures
i i know that i wouldn't enjoy their
light as much
and i would like to be associated with
something i would dislike them i'd be
like yeah look at that oh my god one
just lit up get up get them out of here
because i wonder that about that like
noise like if it's truly that if it
weren't for
the fact that it like preceded
an annoying stint by
would it be that annoying sound it
wouldn't be as annoying
it would still be a little annoying like
that sound is like
like you associate that with like
like if a human did that yeah like
they're like people like need stuff yeah
can you like get me this thing or like
pinch or anything
but this one's it's also so jarring
because it appears it comes in so
suddenly
you